tenemos que hacer la multiplicación 10 3
por 5 a cuadrada más 7 a menos 1 muy
bien vamos a utilizar la ley
distributiva para distribuir este
trinomio en cada uno de los términos
vamos a estar multiplicarlo por 10
y luego vamos a multiplicarlo por menos
3 entonces que nos queda multiplicando
por 10 y nos queda 10 ha multiplicado
por 5 a cuadrada +7 a menos 17 a menos 1
ya eso tenemos que restar tres veces el
trinomio menos tres por el trinomio
entonces es menos 35 cuadrada más 7 a
menos 1 muy bien vamos a desarrollar y
ahorita simplificamos entonces 10 a por
5 a cuadrada 10 por 5 50 a pura
cuadradas a kubica 10 por 7 a 10 por 7
70 a por aysa cuadrada y luego menos 10
a porque 10 a por menos 1 es menos 10
vamos con esta segunda parte
menos tres por cinco a cuadrada es menos
15 a cuadrada menos 3 por 7 es menos 21
y aquí tenemos una
y finalmente menos 3 por menos uno menos
por menos es más entonces nos da más
tres muy bien ya casi terminamos nada
más tenemos que juntar términos
similares por ejemplo este de acá este
50 al cubo bueno ese no tiene ningún
acompañante lo ponemos 50 al cubo sin
embargo hay dos términos con la cuadrada
y este de aquí este el 70 al cuadrado y
el menos 15 al cuadrado
si tenemos 70 de algo y le restamos 15
nos quedan 55 entonces sería más 55 más
55 a cuadrado también hay dos términos
con menos diez y menos 21 déjame tomar
este color este color de acá amarillo
entonces menos 10 menos 21 es menos 31
serían estos dos términos de aquí
y este
y finalmente ese 3 pues ese 3 queda
solito verdad es la constante y nos
quedó así nada más solita sería más 3 ok
entonces ya simplificamos y terminamos
esto de aquí es el resultado de la
multiplicación